urgence à la résidence fourcassa au
deuxième étage de la fumée s'échappe
d'une chambre et le locataire est encore
à l'intérieur les pompiers parviennent à
localiser l'origine du feu et découvre
le résident inanimé qui n'est autre
qu'un mannequin
tout ceci n'est qu'une simulation dans
laquelle pompiers et membres du
personnel de cette résidence pour
personnes âgées sont complices une
demi-heure avant le sergent myriam
clément met en scène l'accident
admettons que le feu soit parti des
plaques
peu importe voilà que l'appartement sera
en fumée peut-être également un petit
peu le couloir qui est là bas avec un
tout petit appareil qui est là
et c'est une des concierges de
l'établissement qui lance l'alertent
sous le regard attentif du sergent oui
bonjour ici la résidence jean fauque à
ça c'est pour un exercice
oui voilà je crois que nous avons a fait
au deuxième étage avec de la fumée au
merci à tout de suite rentré dans son
appartement ne pas bouger et attendre
que l'on vienne toquer à sa porte
secrétaire est agent d'entretien se sont
mis dans la peau des résidents détresse
derrière le véhicule d'assistance aux
blessés elles se remettent de l'exercice
j'étais un petit peu gêné par les faits
mais oui sinon ça s'est bien passé vous
la pomme vient de sa non pas du tout pas
du peu mais c'est bien de le faire parce
que comme ça au moins ça nous apprend
aussi les occupants étaient informés
depuis quelques jours mais aujourd'hui
il n'était pas obligé de participer à
l'évacuation pour ceux qui avaient
oublié passée la surprise ils ont pris
part malgré eux à la simulation
ben moi j'étais en course et quand je
suis revenue on va dire oui descendez en
bas on veut pas me voir là pourquoi
ah bah non parce que pour évacuer les
amener c'est impressionnant c'est un
exercice pour les résidents mais aussi
pour les hommes des femmes du feu dans
ce lieu un peu particulier la différence
est justement vouloir prendre en compte
ces personnes qui sont certainement
mobilité réduite ou avec des déficiences
donc du coup ça nous ça nous permet de
nous adapter à cette population là la
caserne de montigny organise ce type
d'opération une fois par mois
chaque année elle gère 800 départs de
feu entre montigny et rap